- They've got
everything you need
for your linen closet
at Boll & Branch.
- Hey Nikki.
- Start over, yeah,
Thomas Lennon?
- Hey Nikki.
This is tough for me because
I come from a long line
of sheet-selling middlemen.
- Okay.
(laughter)
- When I hear,
I love hearing about this
wonderful company and how,
- Yeah, I'm sure you do.
- They've got
these great sheets,
but keep in mind there
are middlemen out there,
- [Andrew] Yeah.
- Mmhmm.
- Who are trying to jack up
the prices on your sheets.
- Well, they need
to find new work.
- Oh my god, this attitude,
I feel is pervasive
in America now.
(laughter)
We used to be a country
of middle people.
(laughter)
Not just men.
- We've got two
middles across the,
(laughter)
- [Thomas] Hi Nikki.
- Partition from us.
Andrew Collin's here, Mike
Recine is here, and now.
- I don't have time to
meet everybody, guys.
(rock music)
- Thomas Lennon is here.
You know him from Reno 911.
He is now the author of
the young adult book,
Ronan Boyle and the
Bridge of Riddles.
- We can say hit.
- Hit.
- Hit book.
I cannot believe,
- Right now.
- You wrote a children's book.
- I know, right?
Who does that?
- You.
- [Thomas] I know.
- [Nikki] It's like,
what is going on, man?
- [Thomas] It's like, dude.
- [Nikki] You are so prolific.
- Take a day off, guy, I know.
- You also have a
series, Teachers,
on TV Land every
Tuesday at ten pm.
This guy is everywhere.
Thomas Lennon, one of the
funniest people that exists.
- Mmhmm, oh thanks, Nikki.
It's nice to see you.
Last time I saw you...
- I can't believe
I'm friends with you.
- I know, it's weird.
Last time I saw you we
were together on like,
one of those game shows
that you have to sit at
for like nine hours straight.
- So many hours.
- And it seems like
it's gonna be fun,
and you're like, and they
throw a ton of money at you
(laughter)
and I'm like, this
is gonna be great!
And like, hey, meet
Kareem Abdul-Jabbar.
And then Kareem Abdul-Jabbar
doesn't say shit to you,
all day and it's really weird.
- Nothing, not a word.
- Was he mad at me?
What happened?
- We talked and yeah.
- He was mad at me.
Because it was like...
- It was you.
- It was just like Kareem's
vibe was so chilly.
- It was not...
- I thought we were
gonna goof around.
- Listen, that taping
hasn't aired yet.
- Right, right,
right, we did a...
- That day was a
little bit like trying.
We did a game show.
- Yes, you, me,
Kareem Abdul-Jabbar.
(laughter)
- Who else was on it?
- Kareem Abdul-Jabbar
and Vivica Fox.
- Yes, that's
right, that's right.
- And then you and me.
The classic foursome.
- Oh my god, gettin'
the gang back together.
(laughter)
Everyone wanted it.
- And then, right before
we're shooting the game show,
the set caught on fire.
- Oh yes!
- So, like nothing happened
for like five hours.
- And then there was a
weird beeping going on,
in my trailer, that you came...
- I came and fixed your trailer.
- Yeah, I was just ...
- Which is kind of how
porno movies start.
(laughter)
- Like, hey Nikki.
- That was so nice of you,
I just remember
being in my trailer,
there's this like
piercing beeping going on.
- Yeah, I'm a mid-Western guy.
- I was just meditating,
I guess I'm just gonna
have to deal with this,
and then Thomas came in.
- It was a carbon
monoxide warning.
(laughter)
- I was just slowing dying.
- And the great thing is,
I came in and I turned off
the thing that was warning you
assuming that you would just
fall down dead at some point.
(laughter)
- It was so fun.
- I either saved your life
or quietly killed you.
- You do a lot of those
shows though, right?
Like, I've done a lot
of those game shows.
Enough.
- Enough.
- That you look at the run,
I didn't know who was gonna
be there until I got there,
and I was hoping for a
good cast, like a fun.
- God, I thought I
was gonna pal around
with Kareem Abdul-Jabbar.
- Did you?
- I was like, what if he and
I get a Vespa with a sidecar.
(laughter)
We're gonna have some
times, me and Kareem.
Then he came in and
be like, hm, hello.
- I just helped him
with his marker a lot.
- And he was so serious when
it came to playing the game.
- [Nikki] Oh.
- What kind of game was this?
- It's called To Tell
the Truth, or something.
- So yeah, it's three people
telling, two of them are lying
but they all say, like
I'm an alligator wrangler.
- (together) I'm an
alligator wrangler.
I am an alligator wrangler.
- And then you have to guess,
and then you ask some questions
to figure out who's...
- I think you're all lying.
- And they all look like
alligator wranglers.
- They do!
You convince, we were
both bad at the game.
- I was really, really
bad at it, yeah.
- We kept losing.
It's a hard game.
- Yeah.
- But it was...
- It was fun to hang out with
your for nine hours though.
(laughter)
- It was so long.
And it was so cold in there.
- But you were also
basically nude,
- Yeah, that's true.
- Which was your,
that was on you.
- That was on me.
That was on my stylist.
You know sometimes you
just, they don't really know
what the vibe of the show
is, and they dress you...
- You were wearing jeans and
like a tiny bit of duct tape.
(laughter)
- No, I was dressed so slutty.
- Like, it worked, yeah.
- I just, sometimes, I just,
you know you go into
these styling sessions.
- Hey, it's show business.
- Exactly.
- Sometimes just go in and win.
- Just...
(laughter)
- Well, you know what
happens all the time
with these stylists, is I
go in for these fittings.
- Tell me about it, I
know it's like my life.
(laughter)
- I'll put on a bra and
they're like that's it!
That's the look, oh
my god, I'm dead!
- Honey, bra, duct tape.
- And then I convince myself
that's all I need to wear
is a bra because in
the fitting it looks...
- Twizzlers, bra.
(laughter)
Glitter, sprinkles.
- And then, oh man, that was...
- Mist.
- Cream cheese.
- Sierra Mist.
- But I was so excited to
be with you on that show,
because I had worked with
you before on At Midnight.
You were an Executive
Producer on At Midnight.
What a fun show that was.
- We competed on that
show I think, and you
- We did, a couple times.
- I'm sure you beat
me a couple times.
- I think I did but you
were also really good...
- I used to lose
that show a lot.
- At that show, too.
- Not, well...
- You weren't?
- I was there a lot.
- You were there a lot.
- Which if that counts as good,
I don't know if
that counts as good.
- I think so, just
participating.
- I participated.
- You won the participation.
- I got most participation.
(laughter)
- You were there a lot.
That was such a fun
show, At Midnight,
and that was the first time
that I had worked alongside you,
having been a fan of
yours for so many years,
so it just like blew my mind
that I got to even meet you.
I of course, know you from your
character Lieutenant Dangle
from the Reno 911
series and movie.
- That's an under-rated,
weirdly, that's an
under-rated movie.
- It's so funny.
- I know.
- I went and saw it in the
theaters, Crestwood Mall.
- Boy I thought that
movie was gonna do better.
- Yeah?
- Yeah.
- Tell me about that.
- You know how every
time, you're like always,
stylists are always
like, just wear a bra?
- Yeah,
- My life is, I thought that
movie was gonna do better.
- Yeah, I mean, so what
does that feel like?
Because you've had your
hands in a lot of movies.
I mean, you've written a lot
of, you write a lot of movies.
- I've got some
hits and some flops.
- Also, Andrew's a
dog walker, so...
(laughter)
- I was, it's been
three weeks, post.
- Yeah.
- I know how you feel.
- What movies have you written?
- I'll go like biggest
hit, biggest flop.
Biggest hit would be Night at
the Museum with Ben Garant.
- Amazing!
- Biggest flop, would
probably be Taxi
with Queen Latifah
and Jimmy Fallon.
(laughter)
- You wrote Taxi?
I've never even seen Taxi,
but of course we
all know about it.
- The Pacifier, with Vin Diesel.
- I mean, this guy.
- Herbie: Fully Loaded.
Hell Baby, um... oh
man, there's a lot.
- Did anyone, did you guys
know that Thomas Lennon
wrote these movies?
- Yeah, thay're
tattooed on my back.
- No, you don't, his IMDB?
(laughter)
- [Nikki] Wow, we don't need...
- My IMDB goes so far,
it's mostly butt crack.
Everything I did in
the 90s just crack.
- What does that feel
like, when you feel like
- When something flops?
- A movie's gonna be,
yeah, when something flops?
When it doesn't go the way...
- Reno 911 was interesting
'cause it opened,
I think today, it would be,
it made 10 million dollars
or something like that.
- Yeah.
- And I was like, it
only, it cost $10,000,000.
- Okay, so that's ...
- Yeah, it was like a moderate,
it ended up making money
in like video and
stuff like that.
But we got called, like
you get a call Monday
from the head of the
studio, and I remember
we got a call from the
head of the studio at Fox.
And he's like, "Boy,
I really thought
"this was gonna
do better, guys."
And like, oh yeah, us too.
And he's like, "That's okay,
I mean, we're friends now,
and everything, but ..."
No, it sucks, it's
like they kinda,
it's like a minor break-up.
- When do you get
the numbers in?
Say it's released
on Friday, right.
- Generally they can tell,
they can track a movie,
here's what's weird,
they can track a movie
the Wednesday before
it comes out, kind of.
'Cause for like real
flops that we've had,
like Taxi, we got a call,
the producer called us to
say he was leaving town
the Thursday night before
it was even coming out,
and he was like, hey
we're all gonna be
radio-active for a while.
Yeah, and then he like left
the country on his jet.
(laughter)
- But was Taxi a bad movie,
or people just
didn't really see it?
- Both, all of the above.
It was both a bad
movie, that no one saw.
So it's a perfect storm.
- That's not your fault though.
- Uh, kind of, kind of.
- He did write it.
- Yeah.
- No, but once you,
but the thing is
that most people don't know
is that you write a script
and it's no longer yours.
Unless you're a producer on it.
- Well, unless you're
doing like art house movies
that you pay for.
- Yeah, so.
- If you're in
big studio movies,
they're gonna chime in for sure.
- Was that a rude awakening
for you, as a screenwriter,
when your first movie kind
of got out of your hands,
and you were like,
what is happening now?
- You know what is weird,
the first movie we wrote
was called, Let's Go To
Prison, based on a book called
You Are Going To Prison,
that Bob Odenkirk directed.
And we actually saw a cut
of it that we really loved,
and then the studio took
the movie away from Bob,
and they're like, and
it was doing okay,
and they're like, let's make
it really upbeat and cheerful,
so there's like a whole new
ending and the first time
I saw the movie with
it's new everything
was in the movie theater.
And I'd brought like
20 people to see it.
And I was like, this
thing sucks, I'm sorry.
And then we all went
to Buca Di Beppo.
(laughter)
- So that can happen.
- All I can say is when
you have a real disaster,
go to Buca Di Beppo after.
(laughter)
You're gonna feel better,
get the lemon chicken.
Try to sit in the Pope Room.
(laughter)
It takes the sting
off of epic failure.
- What is the most obnoxious
thing about this business?
- About the movie business?
- Yeah, about just, the
business in general.
If there's one thing you
could change about it,
like is there something that,
have you just like
accepted everything?
- The big thing I would say is
just don't take it personally.
It's not personal.
- Have you done that at times?
- Oh sure, if, as soon
as you can get over
taking everything personally,
Ben and I actually wrote,
so we have a book out now,
it's not my first book,
but the first book I
ever wrote was called,
Writing Movies for
Fun and Profit.
- That's right!
- And "Fun and" is crossed out.
So it's actually called
Writing Movies for Profit.
(laughter)
And the big thing that we
say is once you can get over
how bad your feelings
are gonna be hurt,
like most of the time, you
can, you'll get through it.
But you gotta get
ready to be like, yeah.
- Pretty...
- Yeah, it's gonna, yeah.
- It's gonna sting.
- Yeah, it's not for everybody.
- It isn't.
But it gets easier, once
you have faced rejection,
and the criticism.
- This is a big
conversation I had
with one of my best
friends, Ken Marino, I said,
you gotta be really careful
as an actor and as a comedian,
that because you're used
to so much disappointment
that at a certain point
you've gotten so good
at being numb to it, that
you also don't experience
any happy parts
or the good part.
- Oh yeah!
- You've gotta be really
careful about that,
'cause you'll get so
good at just being like,
I don't care, I
didn't care anyway.
You gotta be careful.
- That's a really good point,
and I read something, I
bought one of those books
you know that's on the
racks at Hudson News
where it's just like
generic titles like,
- Like how you're
gonna do something?
- Mental Toughness.
- Right.
- Like it was called
Mental Toughness.
And it was just a bunch of
different articles about it,
and one that I read that
really resonated with me,
is that athletes that
are like, elite athletes,
when they suffer, so
they have the Olympics
to look forward to
every four years, right.
And in between that is all
these World Championships,
and World Championships
mean a lot to them.
Now if they lose at
a World Championship
and they let that defeat
really get to them,
then they aren't gonna be
ready to start training
for the Olympics which
is still on their plate
coming up in a
couple years anyway.
So they've learned to not,
to take a hit and to be like,
that hurt, that sucked
but not to wallow in it,
because otherwise you'll
lose out on training
but also they talk a lot about
how they celebrate their wins.
They really go hard and like,
because I think to your point,
we don't let in the
happiness either.
- Yeah, you gotta,
you can't get so good
at being numb to stuff that
you don't notice the good.
- How do you celebrate?
- I don't really.
- How are you going to celebrate
the release of this book,
Ronan Boyle and the
Bridge of Riddles.
- It's a hit, right
now, it's number one
in Children's Europe Books
on Amazon by the way.
- Really?
- I'm crushing the Who
Was Princess Diana book.
(laughter)
I'm just saying, that's
the number two spot,
I'm the number one spot.
- In the UK?
- My life long goal was,
there'll be a children's book
explaining Princess
Diana to children,
and I will crush
it with my might.
- How are you so good
at so many things?
How did you write,
when did you get into
children's literature,
when did you go, I'm
gonna take a stab at that?
I mean, you've written movies
for the same kind of age group.
- And it's more sort
of like young adult,
actually, a funny adult
could read it too.
- Yeah.
- So, it's really for
like, high school kids,
who are funny or grownups
who like funny stuff.
- Great.
- And the answer is
I write compulsively,
so I'm always doing something.
- You write compulsively?
- I do, yeah.
- You wake up every
morning and write,
or what's your writing...
- Yeah, or I'll write late.
Yeah, sometimes.
- And is it therapeutic for you?
Do you feel like if you
don't, what is the desire?
- I'll be sad,
if I don't do it, I'll be sad.
- Really?
- Yeah.
- Has it always been that
way for you with writing?
- For a long, long time.
As soon as I got in the
state, and I realized
you had to write to like
be in the show and survive,
it started to become a
little bit of a compulsion.
- Yeah, well it's worked out.
This is, we're gonna actually
have our resident lisper
read, Andrew has a
lisp, and we're gonna,
we picked a very lispy part
of your book for him to read.
- Let's do it.
- Would you mind?
- No.
- I didn't know
this was... okay.
- Oh, you didn't know
this was gonna happen,
but just start.
- Now, everyone in the book
has Irish accents also,
so I hope you've
been working on it.
(laughter)
- Dar dar dar dar.
- That's it.
Wait, what was that?
(laughter)
- Dar dar dar.
- This is Ronan Boyle and
the Bridge of Riddles.
- Where am I going?
"Oy, Nobster..."
- Oh dear!
(laughter)
Oh no, it's going great so far.
- "Said a scratchy voice,
"three figures were
squirreling down at me.
"The leader of the group
was Big Jimmy Gibbons,
"the sweatiest person
I have ever met.
"Honestly, I have no
idea why his nickname
"isn't Sweaty Jimmy, because
he's not even that big.
"His sweatiness
and his nastiness
"are his most defining traits.
"Stove cots ain't for nobsters,
ya daft nob - newbster."
Newbster?
- How did I not know...
- If you need someone to read
the Audible version of this.
- First of all I read
the Audible version,
but that's because I didn't
know Andrew was available.
(laughter)
- You coulda got me so cheap.
- So, next time just
check the avails.
By the way they didn't
pay me much for it either,
so before... yeah.
- Can I keep reading?
No, like to myself.
(laughter)
- Oh, yourself, yeah,
keep reading to yourself.
- I'll let you know when I uh...
- That's your copy.
Ronan Boyle and the
Bridge of Riddles,
is a new book by Thomas Lennon.
Funny, you said for
high school kids,
and for adults to enjoy equally.
- Yeah, I think, like
Patton gives a quote
on the back of the
book, which is,
Andrew will you read
the Patton quote?
- Andrew, yes, please
read Patton's quote?
- "Ronan Boyle," which is you,
- The book, yeah.
- Or the book, I'm just funning,
- He's based on me, yeah.
- "Ronan Boyle and
the Bridge of Riddles,
"is a touching, funny read
for smart kids, young and old.
"Flat out laughed out
loud - Patton Oswalt"
And then Weird Al, "In my
completely unbiased opinion,
"my good friend Thomas
Lennon has written perhaps,
"the most finest children's
book of all time,
"in the every burgeoning
leprechaun crime drama subgenre.
"Equal parts J.K. Rowling
and Douglas Adams,
"which you know, ain't
a bad thing - Weird Al."
- Ah, that's great!
- [Andrew] Beautiful, right?
- I know.
- You have a, more
books are to come right?
- This is the first
of three, yeah.
- Featuring Ronan Boyle.
- Yeah.
- Oh, that's so exciting.
- Second one I just finished.
- This is a great birthday gift,
a great what holiday
is coming up?
- St. Patrick's Day.
- I mean, St. Patrick's
Day gift, for your kid.
- Nikki, what was that?
- Those people
don't read though.
What holiday's coming up?
- I mean, do you get
St. Patrick's day gifts?
- Yes!
Of course you do.
- Okay, well now you do.
I'm telling you, Thomas
Lennon there's really no,
he's one of the funniest
people I can imagine.
And like, you are seriously,
one of my favorites.
I watch your stuff all the time,
I've been a fan for so long,
and I'm really excited
about your books
and I'm excited for kids to,
we need more funny literature
- Oh, thanks.
- For young adults,
and this is it.
Ronan Boyle and the
Bridge of Riddles,
get it, order it on Amazon,
I'm guessing it's where...
- Uh yeah, also if you go, if
you get it at Barnes & Noble
there's a special
edition that comes with
the trainees manual in the
back, so I would get that one.
- Oh, get that one.
- But obviously get
it wherever you like.
- And Nikki I had only
one other questions,
which is when is
this gonna be on?
- Three weeks.
- Three weeks from now?
Great, cool.
(laughter)
- Uh wait, do we
have to go to break?
Did I get, do we, good.
We have more time,
good, I wanna ask.
- Are we gonna drag
those sheet middle-men
through the garbage again.
(laughter)
- [Thomas] Sheet middle-men.
- How do you feel
about Warby Parker?
You hate 'em?
- The glasses people?
I used to know people
that would sell, my family
used to sell expensive
glasses that you didn't want
in prescriptions that
were not that great,
so as long as they're
not against that,
I should be fine with
Warby Parker I think.
- I think we should move on,
- In frames and styles
that you do not want.
- Do you like Tom shoes?
- I'm gonna like
fan-girl out a little bit
and ask you about your
character Lieutenant Dangle
from Reno 911.
- Yeah, sure.
- Can we talk about the shorts
and how those came to be?
- The way the shorts
came to be is,
I was like, this guy
should have shorts,
and then the costume
designer brought in
like a normal pair of khakis,
and I was like, no no no no no,
I don't think you understand.
(laughter)
I was like, I want it
to be like so weird,
like weird that
you can't look way.
So I ended up, the only
reason I found out,
I just went smaller and
smaller and smaller,
(laughter)
and then the reason
I found out how big
they actually are is
because in the movie,
the Reno 911 movie, you
see me making a pair.
(laughter)
Like in an emergency, I
make a pair of the pants,
so they're actually
from the waist band
to the hem, is 11 inches.
- Wow.
- So it's a really small short.
- Really small short.
Were those uncomfortable?
- Oh, hurt like hell for years.
- Yeah, I bet.
- Feels horrible.
- What would you
wear underneath that?
Just a pair of briefs?
- Briefs, regular briefs.
But sometimes, since we're
gettin' into it, Nikki,
sometimes they gave
me smooth briefs,
so you wouldn't get a bunch
of crinkly lines and such.
- Yeah yeah yeah.
- You've got stylists,
you know all about this.
- I know exactly.
It makes me feel good that
you as a man have experienced
the tightness and
all the stuff that.
- Yeah.
- I mean, wearing, I was, I
got to portray Kurt Cobain
on a show that's
coming out on Netflix,
where I just dressed
like a boy on TV.
And it was the greatest
time I've ever had on TV.
- I'm excited to see that.
- Thank you.
- Yeah.
- It's called Historical Roasts,
it's where comedians
dress as dead celebrities
and roast each other in heaven.
- Oh my god.
- Yeah, it's good.
But I didn't know I was gonna,
I thought I was gonna
play Princess Diana.
That's what was
originally pitched to me,
so I got to set being
like, I'm ready.
And they were like,
you're Kurt Cobain.
And it was, I was scared,
because I've never.
- Who were you roasting with?
Is Jeff Ross?
- Jeff Ross, he's
the producer of it.
- Jeff got me into the
Friars Club, in 1996.
- Really?
- Oh yeah, I've been a
Friar, since the 90's.
- Do you go there a lot?
- I was there on Friday.
- What?
- Yeah!
- What do you do there?
- Have soup.
(laughter)
But, like I pay like
thousands of dollars a year
to get to go there
and have the soup.
- Okay, yes, so it's.
- Well worth it.
(laughter)
- What, like literally,
what happens in there?
- Literally nothing.
- Nothing, but you did
go there on Friday.
- No, there's a barber shop.
I do, every time,
because I live in LA,
but I'm a member of
Friars Club New York,
so whenever I'm in town
I feel this obligation
like I gotta go to
the Friars Club.
- But what, you just show up,
or do you tell them
you're gonna come?
- No, you tell them you're
coming and make a big deal,
and they're like...
- Is there a show that
goes on there every night?
- No...
- It's just a bunch of
people sitting around.
- There's soup, there's older,
do you like older people?
- Yeah...
- Do you like soup?
- Yeah.
- Do you like, I'm trying to
think of what else is there?
- You got me.
- Pictures, so there's
a lot of pictures
of like Trump on the wall,
and like Harvey Weinstein,
so my joke, from
like back in the day,
- Oh right.
- So my joke is that we have
more predators on the wall
at the Friars Club, than at the
National Geographic Society.
(laughter)
- Oh yeah, they all
hung out there too.
- Yeah.
- It's a boy's club right?
- Used to be, they
started talking ladies...
- Gloria Allred was the
first one to be like,
Girls deserve to be in here!
- Right, and then
they were like,
we don't need to be in here.
- Yeah, just like
soup and old men.
- Soup and farts.
- I feel good.
Yeah, Gloria Allred
was the first person,
I ran into her at another
place that reminds me
of the Friars Club, I ran
into her at the Magic Castle.
- Oh yeah, old-timey
soupy place.
- Such an old man soup place.
And I saw her, you know she
was also in the Michael Jackson
documentary, as
she's the one that...
- I haven't seen it yet.
- Oh yeah, don't wanna
spoil it but, he...
- He's weird, yeah?
- Nah.
- [Nikki] Little weird.
- No he's cool.
Eats soup though.
- Oh, he's totally cool, okay.
- But uh, no I was, I wanted
to like walk up to her
and be like thank you
for all you do for women,
and victims, but she was
having dinner with like,
her nephew or something and
I didn't want to bother her.
But my friend was
like, you have to!
And so, he pulled, of course
a man, pulled me over to her
and was like, she loves you.
And then she goes,
"here's my card, honey.
"If you ever need anything."
And she was like,
what do you do honey,
kind of getting
it out of the way.
I was like, I'm a comedian.
She's like, you know you can
go to the Friars Club now,
because of me, and I
was like, thank you.
- Thank you.
(laughter)
- I'm still not in, actually.
Thomas can you get me in?
- Oh of course.
- Really?
- Yeah, yeah yeah.
- Okay, yeah, again.
- This just in, if
it's Warby Parker...
(laughter)
- It's not Warby Parker.
Thomas Lennon was our guest,
thank you so much
for being here.
Again, his book, Ronan Boyle
and the Bridge of Riddles
is available everywhere now.
Get it at Barnes & Noble for
a special edition of the book.
Order this for whatever
teen you have in your life,
who is interested in comedy,
who is interested in magic,
leprechauns, St. Patrick's Day.
- Yeah.
- I mean, there is no one
funnier than Thomas Lennon,
and now he is writing
young adult fiction,
and I'm excited for kids to
get a chance to read this.
Ronan Boyle and the
Bridge of Riddles.
Be the cool aunt or uncle in
your niece or nephew's life,
and pick up this book for them
for whatever occasion
they have coming up.
- St. Patrick's Day.
- Oh, that's right,
that's right, again.
- By the way, my last question,
when is this gonna be on?
- Four weeks now.
- Yeah, four weeks,
it just moved.
- It's getting further away?
(laughter)
- Yeah, it's bad.
- That's really weird.
We got stacked behind
something else.
Yikes.
Are we behind the Jenny
McCarthy show now?
- [Mike] Didn't wanna tell you.
- God, I'm so jealous of her.
She wears sunglasses in
all of her interviews,
'cause like as a
woman, that's a dream.
- [Mike] Strong.
- It's a bold choice.
- As an aging woman, all I
wanna do is cancel out my eyes.
Thomas Lennon, thank you
so much for being here.
- Always a pleasure,
you're the best.
- You're the best.
Guys, when you're
selling online,
getting your orders out the
door quickly can be tough.
That's why you need
ShipStation.com,
it's a fast and easy way to
manage and ship your orders.
All from one place, ShipStation
helps you get orders
out quickly and keep
customers happy.
- Nikki I'm sorry, but my
family's been in the business
of shipping things from a
bunch of different places
at a bunch of
inconvenient times,
- Well, I hate to
tell you this but...
- On their schedule.
- Your family needs to look
into a different business,
because ShipStation is really.
- It's what we do.
(swipe sound)
(laughter)
- Oh god, do you, what are,
if that's the disgusting habit
you do like out in public,
what are you doing in private?
- Sometimes I'll fart in my
hand, and smell my own hand,
smell my own fart.
You ever do that?
- I honestly think that
you're being serious.
- I am being serious.
Why would I lie?
- Why would you do that?
- I don't know.
Sometimes you just want the
smell of your own scent.
(rock music)
- Do you get a lot of
feedback on the show,
about me being mean to you?
- Yeah.
- Do people think I bully you?
- Uh hmm.
- So tell me a little
bit about that,
because you've never
really let me know,
I've had you say it to
people in front of me, like,
some people say that
Nikki bullies me.
And that's the first
time I hear it.
- What about just now,
when you just did that?
- I don't know what they
could be talking about,
when, I honestly don't know
what they're talking about
when, 'cause sometimes
you'll tell me like,
hey Nikki, so my brother
thinkth that you bully me
thometimeth, and
you make fun of me.
- Uh huh.
- And I don't even
understand what they mean.
- I think it could
be your voice.
What you just did.
Kay, do it again.
(laughter)
What was that, oh no.
- Thathafrath.
- Yeah, that thing.
- Well, say the word sassafras,
and let's see if I'm
really that far off.
- Pretty sure you're
bullying me now.
Sassafras.
- Don't try to be funny.
- Fine, sassafras.
(laughs)
South of France.
- Say, I had some
sassafras, um...
- From a succotash.
- I had some sassafras
and succotash in
the South of France.
Do it.
- I had some sa - wait.
Do it again, one more time.
- Let's go have some
sassafras and succotash
in the South of France.
- Let's go have some
sassafras and succotash
in the South of France.
Not bad.
- What's the scariest
thing for you on a plane?
- Um, sitting next to you.
(laughter)
- You're not wrong.
- I'm not right.
- Wait a second, what do
you hate more than anything
when you fly, truly?
Sitting next to me?
Is it really that bad?
- Turbulance.
- No what is it?
- Turbalence.
- Try to say it right.
- Turbulance.
Turbulence.
Do I have food in my
teeth, is that the problem?
Turbelence.
Tur-Bu-Lence.
- There we go, there we go.
We got there, we got there.
What about, if you were in
plane crash and survived,
what would they
send to come get you
to take you to the hospital?
After the turbu-lance.
- Oh, an ambulance.
- Huh?
- Ambelance.
- How do you say it?
- Ambulance.
Am-Bu-Lance.
Ambulance.
- There you go.
- See, I mean, you try
so hard with words.
- What did you say today
that was just so not right.
You said it yesterday, and
you tried to get through,
and you tried to, oh there
was some word, that...
- Accessible.
- Oh god.
(laughter)
Oh god, okay, wait a second,
so what do you want your
comedy to be to people?
- Assessible.
- What?
- You said assessable, so
you want people to be able to
assess it?
- Uh hmm.
- And like give notes on it?
- No, I want them...
- Or do you want it to
be able to reach people?
- More relatable.
- Okay, so what's the word?
- Assessible.
Accessible.
- (together) Accessible.
- Accessible.
Spell it?
- A-C-C-E-S-S-A-B-L-E.
- I don't know if that's right.
I think it's an I, at the end.
- Where?
- Somewhere.
(laughs)
Does this count as bullying
just making you say words?
- No, I think...
- What could I do to make it
count as bullying, because...
- Yeah, I think it is bullying.
I think to the outside
people, I think they don't,
like my mom, doesn't
appreciate it.
- Oh, you're mom doesn't.
Tell me, tell me!
So your mom listens,
and she doesn't...
- No my mom doesn't
like the comments
that you leave on my Instagram.
- Oh, really?
- Uh huh.
- Like which ones really
got her upset the most.
- Probably the one where
you called her a fat whore.
- I did not do that!
- Yeah, you did.
- I DMed you that.
- Oh that was DM,
yeah that was a DM.
(laughs)
- I did not say
that, by the way.
So your mom is not a
fan of how I bully you.
- No, my mom is a
huge fan of yours,
and she thinks you've
helped me a shit-tonne,
but she also doesn't understand
why you're so mean to me.
- Doesn't she understand
that that's part of why
you're successful, is
because I'm mean to you.
- I don't know if
that's part of it.
- I don't know
that it is either,
I think that's what bullies
say, so that they...
- I think you just
gaslighted me.
- I did.
- Yeah.
- I think you enjoy it.
- I do.
(laughter)
Cheers.
(rock music)